- What is Oprah's one word?
So as you guys probably know by know
I've written a book
called "Your One Word,"
which is about finding your one core value
that makes you come alive,
that represents who you are,
when you understand what you stand for,
then you can build a life
and a business with meaning
and purpose and that is valuable.
And so I thought what might be interesting
is showing off some famous entrepreneurs
and understanding what is their one word
that makes them tic.
Up first, Oprah Winfrey.
- What is your brand do you think?
- I'm the love brand.
- Aren't we all darling?
- [Oprah] No I'm the love brand.
- Aren't we all.
- I'm the love brand.
- You like to shower love around?
- Yeah, it's really, that's what it is,
I am the love and connection brand.
- [Piers] Love that!
- That's what I am.
- You're a bit like Barry
White, the love god,
you're the love brand.
- I'm the love brand because ultimately
everything that I'm saying whether it's in
my magazine, whether
it's Gayle on the radio,
whether it's the Oprah Winfrey Show
and now everything about the channel OWN,
it's about opening your
space, you heart space
so that you can love more.
You know that's really all money is for,
money's worth nothing if it can't buy you
the opportunity to love more.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I hope you enjoyed the clip.
I'd love to know what your one word is
if you want to leave it
down in the comments below,
again I appreciate your viewership,
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is,
much love and I'll see you soon.